(man) TONIGHT,
HOPEFUL ENTREPRENEURS
WHO BELIEVE THEY HAVE
THE NEXT BIG BUSINESS IDEA
WILL ENTER THE SHARK TANK
SEEKING THE FINANCIAL BACKING
TO MAKE THEIR DREAMS
COME TRUE.
I HAVE, RIGHT NOW, A HOME
SHOPPING NETWORK PURSUING ME.
I HAVE NEVER HAD AN IDEA
IN THE SHARK TANK
THAT I LOVE THIS MUCH.
IT‐‐IT IS PRETTY AMAZING.
THE SHARKS
ARE READY TO INVEST
USING THEIR OWN MONEY,
BUT ONLY
FOR THE RIGHT PERSON...
I GOTTA TRY THIS.
WITH THE RIGHT IDEA.
YEAH, BABY.
GERBIL IN THE RAT RACE.
BUT FIRST, THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST CONVINCE A SHARK
TO INVEST THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
ARE YOU SAYING
YOUR PRODUCT CURES DISEASE
AND CANCER IN PETS?
NOT CURE, PREVENT.
GEOFFREY, IF THAT'S TRUE,
WHY AREN'T YOU IN A REAL
HOSPITAL SAVING HUMANKIND?
WOW.
AND IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GOOD IDEA,
THEY'LL FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A PIECE OF IT.
THERE IS NO NEED FOR BARBARA
IN THIS DEAL.
WHO ARE YOU KIDDING?
YOU ARE GUILTY
OF MURDERING MONEY.
YOU'RE GOING TO GO TO JAIL.
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
KEVIN O'LEARY
IS A VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO STARTED A SOFTWARE BUSINESS
IN HIS BASEMENT,
WHICH HE EVENTUALLY SOLD
FOR $3.2 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN
IS A FIERY REAL ESTATE MOGUL
WHO TURNED A $1,000 LOAN
INTO AN EMPIRE
WORTH HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS.
KEVIN HARRINGTON
IS THE KING OF INFOMERCIALS.
HIS GENIUS MARKETING
OF PRODUCTS
HAS AMASSED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN SALES.
DAYMOND JOHN
TURNED RAGS TO RICHES
WITH HIS CLOTHING BRAND FUBU,
WHICH HAS GROSSED
OVER $6 BILLION.
AND ROBERT HERJAVEC,
A TECHNOLOGY TYCOON
WHO SOLD HIS INTERNET COMPANIES
FOR OVER $350 MILLION.
(man) ♪ THE BEST THINGS
IN LIFE ARE FREE ♪
♪ BUT THAT AIN'T REALLY
GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME ♪
♪ I NEED MONEY ♪
♪ THAT'S WHAT I WANT ♪
♪ WHAT I WANT ♪
FIRST INTO THE SHARK TANK
IS DAN MACKEY
WITH A HEALTHY VERSION
OF AMERICA'S FAVORITE BEVERAGE.
♪♪
MY NAME'S DAN MACKEY, AND I LIVE
IN SAUSALITO, CALIFORNIA.
I'VE CREATED
A HEALTHY ALTERNATIVE
TO SOMETHING AMERICANS CONSUME
IN HUGE QUANTITIES.
I HAVE A FEW TEACHERS
IN MY FAMILY,
AND THEY WERE AMAZED
THAT WHEN CALIFORNIA WAS
GETTING RID OF SODAS
FROM SCHOOL CAMPUSES,
THE THINGS THEY BROUGHT IN
TO REPLACE THEM
WEREN'T ANY HEALTHIER.
THEY WERE JUICES
AND SPORTS DRINKS THAT STILL HAD
AS MANY CALORIES OR MORE THAN
THE SODAS THEY REPLACED.
IT'S LIKE, "OH, THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY,
YOU KNOW, HELP ADULTS
AND KIDS AND EVERYONE."
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
GREAT IDEAS,
AND IT'S JUST A MATTER
OF DOING SOMETHING ABOUT IT
AND SEEING A NEED
AND SEEING THAT NO ONE ELSE
IS MAKING THIS HAPPEN‐‐
WELL, I GUESS MAYBE I SHOULD‐‐
AND SO THAT'S WHAT I'VE DONE.
HI. MY NAME'S DAN MACKEY.
CAN I SPEAK WITH
YOUR BEVERAGE MANAGER, PLEASE?
I'M A MARKETING GUY.
I KNOW WHAT SELLS.
I DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE
THE ENTREPRENEURIAL EXPERIENCE.
I'VE NEVER BROUGHT A PRODUCT
TO MARKET.
I'M NEW TO THIS,
SO I NEED THE SHARKS' HELP.
WITH THEIR INVESTMENT
AND THEIR EXPERTISE,
I KNOW WE CAN REALLY
MAKE SOMETHING OF THIS.
♪♪
HI, MY NAME'S DAN MACKEY,
AND I AM THE CREATOR
OF CHILL SODA.
I AM SEEKING
A MINIMUM INVESTMENT OF $50,000
FOR 10% EQUITY.
CHILL IS A TRULY HEALTHY LINE
OF SODA.
I HAVE SOME TEACHERS
IN MY FAMILY.
WHEN CALIFORNIA WAS GETTING RID
OF SODAS FROM SCHOOL CAMPUSES,
WE SAW WHAT
THEY REPLACED THEM WITH‐‐
THESE DIET SODAS
THAT ARE FULL OF CHEMICALS
THAT NO ONE WANTS TO DRINK,
JUICES FULL OF SUGAR.
AND I'M LIKE, "IS THIS
THE BEST THEY GOT?
"IF SOMEONE WANTED TO MAKE
A BOATLOAD OF MONEY,
THEY SHOULD INVENT A HEALTHY
SODA." OH, GUESS WHAT. I DID.
CHILL IS
UNIQUELY LOW GLYCEMIC.
IT'S ORGANIC, IT HAS
NO HIGH‐FRUCTOSE CORN SYRUP,
NO SIMPLE SUGARS,
IT'S NUTRITIOUS,
IT'S LIGHT IN CALORIES,
IT HAS ANTIOXIDANTS, VITAMINS,
BUT THE BEST THING‐‐
IT TASTES LIKE REGULAR SODA.
IT IS GOOD.
I BROUGHT A FEW SAMPLES...
OKAY.
I'D LOVE FOR YOU TO TASTE.
IS THERE AN ARTIFICIAL SWEETENER
IN HERE?
(Robert) THANKS, DAN.
THERE IS
NO ARTIFICIAL SWEETENER.
BECAUSE "ORGANIC" MEANS
THERE'S NO CHEMICALS,
NOTHING ARTIFICIAL WHATSOEVER.
THANK YOU.
WE USE SOMETHING CALLED
AGAVE NECTAR...
OH, THAT WAS PRETTY GOOD.
IT'S GOOD.
AND THAT'S NUTRITIOUS LIKE
HONEY, BUT IT'S LOW GLYCEMIC.
AND IT'S ACTUALLY SWEETER
THAN SUGAR,
SO WE'RE ABLE TO GET
THE SAME SWEETNESS LEVEL
FOR LESS CALORIES.
HOW MANY CALORIES IN ONE CAN?
IN ONE CAN,
WE HAVE 85 CALORIES.
THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
YOUR TYPICAL SODA IS 140,
AND A LOT OF THE ORGANIC SODAS
ON THE MARKET ARE,
LIKE, 160, 180.
OKAY, DAN,
HERE'S A QUESTION FOR YOU.
SURE.
WHAT IS THE THING
THAT IS THE ULTIMATE LEVERAGE
OF SUCCESS
FOR ALL PLAYERS
IN THE BEVERAGE MARKET?
I HOPE YOU KNOW THIS ANSWER.
YOU GOTTA TASTE GOOD.
NO, NO, NO. NO. NO.
NO. INCORRECT.
WHAT DO YOU NEED
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE RIGHT NOW
AND IS THE REASON
YOU'RE STANDING IN FRONT OF ME?
WELL...
YOU GOTTA GET THIS.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO ANSWER IT
FOR ME, 'CAUSE I‐‐
DISTRIBUTION.
SHELF SPACE.
RIGHT. OKAY. SORRY. I THOUGHT
THAT WAS A GIVEN, BECAUSE‐‐
YOU DON'T HAVE IT.
OH, ACTUALLY, I DO.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE?
WE ACTUALLY ALREADY HAVE
A DISTRIBUTOR ON BOARD.
THEY'RE
IN 40 DIFFERENT TERRITORIES
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES,
SO WE'RE ROCKING AND ROLLING
ALREADY.
DAN, IS THERE A STORE
THAT I CAN GO INTO TODAY
AND SEE YOUR PRODUCT
ON THE SHELF?
THERE IS NOT,
BECAUSE YOU'RE GETTING IN
ON THE GROUND FLOOR
OF THIS THING.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SALES?
WE ALREADY HAVE SOLD 250 UNITS,
AND WE HAVE, YOU KNOW, WE'RE‐‐
250 UNITS‐‐CASES OR PIECES?
CANS.
OKAY...
(laughs)
HOW MUCH DOES 250 CANS OF SODA
AT APPROXIMATELY 40 CENTS EQUAL?
WELL, $175,000.
HOW‐‐WHOA, WHOA,
WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
HOW MANY HAVE YOU SOLD?
250,000 CANS.
(Harrington) 250,000.
THOUSAND.
(O'Leary) ALL RIGHT.
YOU SAID 250 CANS.
I'M SORRY. YEAH, THAT'S NOT
VERY MANY CANS, IS IT?
SO HOW MANY DOLLARS...
(laughs) NO.
HOW MANY DOLLARS HAVE‐‐HAVE YOU
COLLECTED IN SALES FROM THAT?
SO B‐‐FROM THAT,
WE GOT $175,000.
THAT'S NOT BAD.
DAN, YOU JUST GAVE YOURSELF
MOUTH‐TO‐MOUTH.
DAN, THE $175,00 IN SALES
THAT YOU GOT‐‐
YOU TOLD ME THAT IT'S NOT
AVAILABLE ON ANY SHELF.
SO WHERE DID YOU SELL
THE $175,000 TO?
THAT WAS SOLD
TO THE DISTRIBUTOR,
AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY HELPING US
WITH THE PRODUCTION RUN.
THEY ARE SO BEHIND IT.
WHY ARE THEY BEING
SO UNBELIEVABLY NICE TO YOU?
BECAUSE THEY HAVE
A GREAT RELATIONSHIP
WITH MY BEVERAGE MANAGEMENT
COMPANY.
WHAT IS
A BEVERAGE MANAGEMENT COMPANY?
BEVERAGE MANAGEMENT‐‐
IS THAT A CONSULTANT?
THEY ARE CONSULTANTS, YEAH.
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW THAT MUCH
ABOUT THE BEVERAGE INDUSTRY.
OOH.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING YOU SHOULD
HAVE JUST SAID TO ME.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING HERE?
(laughs)
WELL, NO. I MEAN, I'M‐‐
DAN, DON'T YOU THINK YOU SHOULD
KNOW THE BEVERAGE BUSINESS
IF YOU'RE GONNA DEVOTE
YOUR LIFE TO IT?
AT LEAST LIE TO ME.
WELL, I'M A MARKETING GUY. I'M
NOT IN THE BEVERAGE INDUSTRY.
YOU KNOW, YOU SHOULD
NEVER HAVE EVER TOLD ME
THAT YOU DO NOT KNOW
THAT BUSINESS. I AM OUT.
YOU'RE GONNA NEED
FAR MORE THAN $50,000
TO GET OVER THE HUMP HERE.
YOU'RE GONNA NEED MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS, AND, UH,
I‐I JUST GOTTA TELL YOU,
YOU GOT A LOT OF GUTS, AND GOOD
LUCK TO YOU, BUT I'M OUT.
(Robert)
DAN, LET ME TELL YOU...
YEAH.
I, UH, I THINK
YOU'RE A GOOD GUY,
BUT I THINK YOU'RE
AN INCREDIBLY NAIVE GUY.
YOU GOTTA BE IN CONTROL
OF YOUR OWN DESTINY,
AND YOU'RE NOT. I'M OUT.
WHEN YOU WOKE UP
TWO YEARS AGO
AND SAID "I WANT TO GO
INTO A BUSINESS,"
WHY DID YOU PICK
THE MOST BRUTALLY COMPETITIVE
CONSUMER GOODS MARKET
IN THE WORLD?
WHAT WOULD MAKE YOU DO THAT?
BECAUSE OF THE BUSINESS MODEL
BEHIND IT.
PART OF WHAT I HAVE TO DO
EVERY DAY IS TO‐‐IS TO TRY
AND FIND OPPORTUNITIES WHERE
I PUT MONEY IN HARM'S WAY...
RIGHT.
AND I GET A RETURN.
I DON'T PICK PLACES
WHERE THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF DEAD
AND ROTTING CORPSES.
THAT'S WHAT
THE BEVERAGE INDUSTRY IS.
IT'S GUYS LIKE YOU
GETTING SLAUGHTERED.
AND LOOK, I DON'T WANT
TO DEPRESS YOU
OR NOT GIVE YOU
THE MOTIVATION YOU NEED.
WHO ARE YOU KIDDING?
I THINK IT'S FRAUGHT
WITH RISK. I'M OUT.
DON'T WORRY, DAN, YOU GOT A LOT
MORE HAIR THAN THIS GUY HAS
AND A LOT MORE ENTHUSIASM.
YOU'RE A LOT MORE POSITIVE
IN MY BOOK.
ARE YOU CUTTING HIM A CHECK?
I'M GONNA TELL YOU WHAT I LIKE
ABOUT THIS. I LOVE THE PRODUCT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO BE AFRAID
OF, SO MAYBE I'M AS NAIVE AS HE.
I GUESS YOU'LL FIND OUT
THE HARD WAY.
HE'S DONE IT RIGHT
FROM THE BEGINNING,
HE'S WORKING FROM HIS HEART,
AND YOU WANT TO KNOW
WHAT I THINK THE BEST TRAIT IS?
YOU'RE NOT SLICK.
YOU STAND THERE
AND YOU ANSWER HONESTLY.
(Robert) HE KNOWS NOTHING.
HEY. LOOK AT THIS GUY.
HE'S A STRAIGHT SHOOTER.
ARE YOU GIVING HIM AN OFFER,
BARBARA?
SHE IS THE TYPE OF PERSON
WE'RE TARGETING.
I MEAN, WE WANT PEOPLE
WHO ARE SMART
AND SEE THE POTENTIAL
IN THIS PRODUCT.
I LOVE THAT
YOU'RE INTERESTED, BARBARA.
BARBARA, PLEASE DON'T
GIVE THIS GUY ANY MONEY. NO!
(Robert) DON'T DO IT.
♪♪
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
BARBARA IS DAN'S LAST CHANCE
AT A DEAL.
I LOVE THAT
YOU'RE INTERESTED, BARBARA.
BARBARA, PLEASE DON'T GIVE
THIS GUY ANY MONEY. NO!
DON'T DO IT.
I AM GONNA WRITE YOU A CHECK.
NO!
ARE YOU CRAZY?
HE'S A THOUGHTFUL GUY. HE'S
CAREFUL WITH WHAT HE'S DOING.
(Daymond) I AM, TOO.
GIVE ME THE MONEY.
I'LL GIVE YOU $20,000
FOR THERAPY.
(laughs)
BARBARA, YOU'RE GONNA CALL YOUR
PARTNER, AND YOU'RE GONNA SAY,
"WELL, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT WE'RE DOING."
HE'S GONNA GO, "ME, NEITHER."
DON'T DO IT.
PLEASE DON'T LECTURE ME.
BARBARA, A MOMENT,
JUST A MOMENT. LISTEN.
I‐I‐I WOULD NEVER DO THIS,
EVER. YOU KNOW THAT.
BUT I FEEL A POWER
IN THE ROOM RIGHT NOW.
(ghostly voice) OOH.
A FORCE IS GUIDING ME, AND IT'S
BEGGING YOU, DON'T DO IT!
YOU MUST BE OUT OF YOUR MIND.
I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE HER
ON BOARD,
'CAUSE ONE, I'D LOVE TO HAVE
A WOMAN'S PERSPECTIVE.
THE OFFER IS FOR THE $50,000,
BUT I NEED TO GET 20%
OF YOUR BUSINESS.
NO!
(groans) I CAN'T TAKE IT.
I CAN'T...
(groans)
(Harrington) TOOK A FLYER.
IS HE IN?
BARBARA, I AM IN.
(Harrington) ALL RIGHT.
I LOVE THAT YOU'RE IN.
BARBARA, THE GUY IS GONNA
GET VAPORIZED
BY THE BEVERAGE INDUSTRY.
YOU'RE GONNA BE SURPRISED.
YOU'RE GONNA BE SO SURPRISED.
NO, VAPORIZED.
THIS IS‐‐BARBARA, THIS IS
REALLY REMARKABLE.
I CAN'T WAIT TO HAVE THEM
GREEN WITH ENVY.
I CAN'T EITHER.
YOU ARE GUILTY
OF MURDERING MONEY.
YOU'RE GOING TO GO TO JAIL.
(imitates bugle
playing "Taps")
THEY ARE GONNA BE SO SORRY
THEY DIDN'T GET IN
ON THE GROUND FLOOR, BARBARA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU ARE SUCH A SWEETIE.
YOU ARE, TOO.
IT TAKES ONE TO KNOW ONE.
(Robert)
WHAT THE HELL HAPPENED HERE?
(Daymond) I DON'T KNOW.
(O'Leary) HAVE YOU LOST
YOUR MIND?
NOT AT ALL. CAN'T WAIT
TO SHOW YOU MY PROFITS.
THANK YOU ALL.
I GREATLY APPRECIATE IT.
BARBARA, WE'LL BE IN TOUCH.
(sharks laugh)
BARBARA, YOU HAVE OFFENDED...
YOU HAVE OFFENDED THE PRIMAL
FORCES OF CAPITALISM HERE.
ENOUGH.
I'M HAPPY WITH THE DEAL.
GOOD LUCK, BARBARA.
GOOD LUCK.
I‐I‐I NEED A DRINK.
I GOT BARBARA ON BOARD,
WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHAT I WANTED TO HAVE HAPPEN,
SO I AM TOTALLY STOKED.
NEXT IN IS
DR. GEOFFREY BRODERICK
AND HIS DAUGHTER KRISTINA
WITH A PRODUCT INSPIRED BY
THEIR LOVE FOR ANIMALS.
♪♪
I'M DR. GEOFFREY BRODERICK,
THIS IS MY DAUGHTER
KRISTINA BRODERICK,
AND OUR COMPANY
IS CORNUCOPIA EXPRESS.
I'VE BEEN A VETERINARIAN
FOR OVER 40 YEARS.
THIS IS A FAMILY PRACTICE.
MY WIFE IS A REGISTERED NURSE.
UM, LOOKS A LITTLE, UM,
LOOKS A LITTLE RED IN THE GUMS.
MY OTHER DAUGHTER MICHELLE
WORKS HERE EVERY DAY.
HOW IS HE?
(makes kissing noises)
(Geoffrey) MY ENTIRE LIFE
AND CAREER
HAS BEEN DEDICATED
TO HELPING ANIMALS.
(whimpers)
WHAT? OH, I KNOW IT. I KNOW.
I CREATED
THESE VERY SPECIAL PRODUCTS
WHICH PROTECT THE ANIMAL
AGAINST DISEASE.
(Kristina) CURRENTLY
OUR PRODUCTS ARE BEING SOLD
AT MY FATHER'S ANIMAL HOSPITAL
IN HUNTINGTON, NEW YORK,
AND ONLINE, BUT I WILL BE
TAKING THIS PRODUCT NATIONALLY
ONCE WE GET THE MONEY
FROM THE SHARKS.
I HOPE AND I KNOW
THE SHARKS ARE GONNA REALIZE
HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS
AND WHAT A DIFFERENCE
THIS IS GONNA MAKE TO THE PET
POPULATION OF THIS WORLD.
♪♪
HI, I'M KRISTINA BRODERICK,
AND THIS IS MY FATHER,
DR. GEOFFREY BRODERICK,
AND THIS IS CASEY.
OUR COMPANY IS
CORNUCOPIA EXPRESS,
AND OUR PRODUCTS ARE
SUPER FOOD AND PHYTO‐FOOD,
WHICH ARE PROBIOTICS
FOR DOGS AND CATS.
WE ARE ASKING FOR $300,000
FOR 15% OF OUR COMPANY.
I DEVELOPED THESE PRODUCTS
TO EXTEND THE LIVES OF PETS
BY 50%.
THESE PRODUCTS SAVE PEOPLE
AND PET OWNERS
TREMENDOUS AMOUNTS OF MONEY
BY KEEPING THEIR PET HEALTHY
AND DISEASE‐FREE.
GEOFFREY, DID YOU SAY YOU EXTEND
THE LIFE OF PETS BY 50%?
YES, 50%.
IS CASEY 28 YEARS OLD?
NOT YET.
NOT YET, BUT CASEY WILL LIVE
TO BE OVER 18.
HOW LONG DOES
A USUAL CASEY LIVE?
UH, THE AVERAGE DOG
IN THE UNITED STATES DIES AT 10.
GEOFFREY, CAN I SEE THE FOOD?
SURE.
AND CAN I SEE CASEY?
(Kristina) OF COURSE.
(Robert) I WANT TO SEE
IF HE'S GONNA EAT IT.
HERE, BABY. HERE, CASEY.
(Kristina) MMM.
OH, LOOK AT THAT.
(O'Leary) OH!
LOOK AT THAT. YOU WANT
TO SEE IF A DOG LIKES IT?
DOC, HOW LONG HAVE YOU BEEN
GIVING THIS PRODUCT
TO YOUR‐‐YOUR PATIENTS?
OVER A QUARTER OF A CENTURY.
WAIT A MINUTE. WHY ARE
WE FEEDING THAT TO A DOG?
WHAT ABOUT ME?
(Barbara laughs)
WILL IT WORK ON PEOPLE?
THIS IS HUMAN‐GRADE.
PEOPLE CAN EAT THIS. HE DOES.
I MAKE A SMOOTHIE EVERY MORNING,
AND I DUMP IT IN THE SMOOTHIE.
IF YOU PUT THIS IN YOUR FOOD,
YOU'LL BE AROUND
TO PLAY WITH ALL THE MONEY
THAT YOU'RE MAKING.
WHAT IS IT? A SUPPLEMENT
I PUT INTO THE PET FOOD?
IT'S A SUPPLEMENT
THAT MAKES THE FOOD WILD AGAIN.
IT BRINGS NATURE
BACK INTO THE FOOD.
BRINGS THE FOOD WILD AGAIN‐‐
I LOVE THAT. DOES IT TASTE GOOD?
TAKE A TASTE. HAVE A BITE.
(Geoffrey) YEAH.
(laughs)
AM I GONNA LIVE FOREVER
IF I EAT THAT?
YOU MIGHT.
(Robert) OH, NO.
(Harrington)
OH, MY GOODNESS.
OH, THAT STINKS.
(Barbara) DON'T DO IT. OH!
(Daymond) CAN I HOLD THE DOG?
IT'S NOT BAD.
BRING ONE OF THOSE OVER HERE.
(Barbara) WHAT DOES IT
TASTE LIKE?
YOU KNOW,
IT'S A LITTLE FUNKY, BUT...
(Robert)
WHAT'S IN IT, GEOFFREY?
(Geoffrey)
THERE ARE ANTIOXIDANTS
AND THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF HERBS
FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD.
HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH THIS?
I HAVE RESEARCHED,
IN THE LAST 40 YEARS,
ALL OVER THE WORLD,
TO BRING THIS TO FRUITION.
THEY COME FROM THE LONGEST
LIVING PEOPLE ON THE PLANET.
IN ASIA AND SIBERIA,
I FOUND‐‐
DURING THIS RESEARCH‐‐
THAT THEIR PETS LIVED‐‐
OUTLIVE OTHER PETS TREMENDOUSLY.
IS THERE SOMETHING PROPRIETARY
ABOUT THIS
OR CAN YOU PATENT THIS?
I'M NOT EVEN CERTAIN.
WE DIDN'T PATENT IT, BECAUSE
IF YOU MAKE OUT A PATENT,
YOU'VE GOT TO DISCLOSE
EVERYTHING THAT'S IN IT,
AND WE DON'T WANT TO MAKE IT
SO THAT IT CAN BE DUPLICATED,
AND PEOPLE HAVE TRIED TO
DUPLICATE IT, AND THEY CANNOT.
CAN YOU MAKE THE CLAIM
THAT FLUFFY LASTS 50% LONGER,
OR DO YOU HAVE TO BACK THAT UP
WITH CLINICAL DATA?
WELL, IT'S‐‐IT'S MY OBSERVATION
OVER 40 YEARS.
THIS CAT IS ROCKY.
(Robert) UH, GEOFFREY...
ROCKY'S 24 YEARS OLD,
LIVES IN COLORADO.
(Daymond and O'Leary) 24?
GEOF‐GEOF‐GEOFFREY,
HANG ON A SEC.
I JUST WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR,
BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE
IF THIS IS A FUN IDEA
OR IF THERE IS AN ELEMENT
OF, UM...
(O'Leary) QUACKERY?
ARE YOU SUGGESTING THAT,
ROBERT?
WELL, SNAKE OIL SALESMAN
ABOUT IT.
(O'Leary) OIL?
WHY DO‐‐WHY DO ANIMALS DIE?
THEY DIE AND THEY PASS AWAY
FOR THE SAME REASONS
AS HUMAN BEINGS‐‐DISEASE...
THEY DIE OF HEART DISEASE,
KIDNEY DISEASE,
LIVER DISEASE, CANCER.
RIGHT. ARE YOU SAYING‐‐
VERY SIMPLE‐‐
THAT YOUR PRODUCT CURES
DISEASE AND CANCER IN PETS?
I'M SAYING
THAT I HAVEN'T HAD A CASE
OF CANCER IN MY HOSPITAL
SINCE I CAN REMEMBER.
DR. BRODERICK, I'M SURE YOU
BELIEVE THAT, BUT IN MY WORLD,
THE FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION
WILL MAKE YOU PROVE THAT.
(Robert) DO YOU HAVE PROOF?
I'VE BEEN A VETERINARY SURGEON
FOR OVER 40 YEARS.
IN THAT 40 YEARS,
I HAVE SEEN
EVERY... DISEASE IMAGINABLE
VANISH FROM MY PRACTICE.
THERE'S ONLY TWO KINDS OF PEOPLE
THAT MAKE THIS KIND OF CLAIM.
THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO TRULY BELIEVE IT
AND ARE IGNORANT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T KNOW ANY BETTER.
AND THEN THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO MAKE 'EM
BECAUSE THEY'RE SLICK CON MEN
TRYING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF PEOPLE'S DESIRES AND NEEDS.
OR THERE'S A VET THAT'S HAD
EXPERIENCE FEEDING THIS TO DOGS
THAT HAVE LASTED A LONG TIME.
IS HE IN THAT CATEGORY?
MAYBE HIS CLAIM IS TRUE,
ROBERT.
I FIND IT...
ALMOST OFFENSIVE...
THAT HE'S CLAIMING HE CAN BEAT
CANCER FOR PEOPLE'S PETS.
HE DIDN'T SAY BEAT CANCER.
DID YOU SAY "BEAT" CANCER?
NO, NOT BEAT, NOT CURE,
PREVENT.
BUT, GEOFFREY, YOU REALIZE
THAT IN A SOCIETY
WHERE 50% OF ALL OF US
WILL PROBABLY GET CANCER
IN OUR OLDER AGE,
WHY I'M BEING VERY SKEPTICAL
ABOUT YOUR FANTASTIC CLAIM?
♪♪
GEOFFREY, YOU REALIZE
THAT IN A SOCIETY
WHERE 50% OF ALL OF US
WILL PROBABLY GET CANCER
IN OUR OLDER AGE,
WHY I'M BEING VERY SKEPTICAL
ABOUT YOUR FANTASTIC CLAIM?
OF COURSE YOU'RE‐‐
YOU'RE BEING SKEPTICAL,
BECAUSE YOU WERE LED
TO BELIEVE
THAT YOU'RE GONNA DIE
OF CANCER OR HEART DISEASE.
AND YOU'VE DISCOVERED
THE ABILITY FOR ME
NOT TO DO THAT BY TAKING THIS?
EXACTLY.
I DISCOVERED THE ABILITY
FOR ME NOT TO GET IT,
FOR YOU NOT TO GET IT
AND YOUR PET NOT TO GET IT.
GEOFFREY, IF THAT'S TRUE,
WHY THE HELL ARE
WE SELLING PET FOOD?
WHY AREN'T YOU
IN A REAL HOSPITAL
GETTING FUNDING FROM PEOPLE
AND SAVING HUMANKIND?
(O'Leary) MAYBE YOU SHOULD.
WHY ARE WE WASTING OUR TIME
SELLING PET FOOD
WHEN YOU CAN CURE CANCER?
BECAUSE THE ANIMALS ARE
MY CHILDREN. THAT'S WHY.
I'M OUT.
DR. BRODERICK,
YOU NEED DOCUMENTATION,
YOU NEED CLINICAL STUDIES.
IT REALLY DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU
BELIEVE IT OR I BELIEVE IT.
ONCE YOU COME INTO
A NATIONAL‐TYPE
ADVERTISING SITUATION,
YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO MAKE THOSE CLAIMS.
THERE IS NO PET FOOD STORE
THAT WILL LET YOU
PUT ON THIS LABEL THE THINGS
THAT YOU'VE SAID HERE TONIGHT.
AND ON THAT NOTE, I'M OUT.
I THINK
YOU'RE TOTALLY CREDIBLE,
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE THE PROOF,
AND FOR THAT, IT'S SOMETHING
I JUST COULD NOT
PUT MY MONEY IN, SO I'M OUT.
DR. GEOFFREY AND KRISTINA,
I LOST BOTH OF MY DOGS
AFTER 13 YEARS.
I LOST THEM LAST YEAR.
BUT I CAN'T LET THE STRINGS
OF MY HEART MAKE THIS DECISION.
I AM OUT.
I, PERSONALLY,
BELIEVE YOUR STORY.
THE CHALLENGE IS
MARKETING THIS STUFF.
ALL WE CAN SAY IS THIS STUFF
LOOKS LIKE IT WORKS,
BUT WE CAN'T MAKE THE CLAIM,
'CAUSE THERE'S NO STUDY
SUPPORTING IT.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
TAKE IT HOME FOR YOUR PET,
BECAUSE YOU'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
THANK YOU, DOCTOR.
♪♪
(Geoffrey)
PREVENTING IS ONE THING.
WE NEVER SAID WE CURED CANCER,
BUT THIS IS WHAT, YOU KNOW,
SOME‐‐SOME PEOPLE WERE HEARING.
GUYS,
WHAT WERE YOU DOING THERE?
THE GUY IS TELLING YOU
HE CAN PREVENT CANCER.
HE DIDN'T SAY THAT.
(Barbara) HE DIDN'T SAY THAT.
(Daymond) HE DIDN'T
SAY THAT, ROBERT.
HE DID NOT SAY THAT.
HE SAID IN HIS CASES‐‐
HIS EXPERIENCE WAS HE HAD
LESS SICKNESS IN HIS PRACTICE.
IT'S EITHER A FACT OR IT ISN'T.
I BELIEVE IN MY FATHER,
AND I BELIEVE IN HIS PRODUCTS,
AND THE BOTTOM LINE IS,
YOU CANNOT PUT A PRICE
OR A DOLLAR SIGN
ON THE LIFE OF AN ANIMAL.
SO I BELIEVE
IN WHAT WE'RE DOING,
AND WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
DOING WHAT WE DO.
JUST WEEKS AGO,
WE MET ENTREPRENEUR
TIFFANY KRUMINS,
AND WATCHED HER STRIKE A DEAL
WITH BARBARA CORCORAN.
TIFFANY, I'VE MADE YOU
A GOOD OFFER.
YES.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO ABOUT IT?
DO YOU WANT IT?
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'D LOVE TO TAKE YOUR OFFER.
I'M SO HAPPY. WE'RE GONNA MAKE
MONEY ON THIS TOGETHER.
CONGRATULATIONS.
HERE'S WHAT SHE'S UP TO NOW.
I WENT INTO THE SHARK TANK,
AND I CAME OUT WITH A $50,000
INVESTMENT FROM BARBARA.
AND I WENT FROM THIS,
MY HOMEMADE PROTOTYPE,
TO OUR FINISHED PRODUCT,
AVA THE ELEPHANT.
(man) I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU
TO STUART AMOS, OUR C. E. O.
TODAY WE'RE AT FLAVORx,
ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES
IN THE U. S.,
AND THEY WANT TO PUT
AVA THE ELEPHANT
IN PHARMACIES
ACROSS THE NATION.
I'LL TAKE UP THE RIGHT AMOUNT
OF MEDICINE.
AVA THE ELEPHANT IS A MEDICINE
DISPENSER FOR CHILDREN.
SHE IS A CUTE LITTLE ELEPHANT
THAT HIDES MEDICINE
IN HER TRUNK.
IT'S GREAT.
IT SEEMS LIKE A PERFECT MARRIAGE
TO, UM, YOU KNOW,
TO BRING YOUR PRODUCT TOGETHER
WITH OUR FLAVORING,
WHICH IS IN 40,000 PHARMACIES
NATIONWIDE.
SINCE FILMING THE SHOW,
I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER.
UM, I HAD TO TAKE
A LITTLE BREAK IN THE MIDDLE
TO, UM, HAVE SURGERY
AND DO RADIATION,
AND NOW I AM CANCER‐FREE
AND BACK TO WORK, SO...
AND I WANT YOU TO KNOW,
SHE NEVER REALLY TOOK A BREAK,
BECAUSE SHE WAS WORKING
FROM THE HOSPITAL BED
RIGHT THROUGH THE WHOLE THING.
AMAZING. JUST AMAZING.
BARBARA AND I ARE JET‐SETTING
AROUND THE WORLD RIGHT NOW,
PRETTY MUCH,
FROM MEETING TO MEETING.
AND EVEN BEING ROMANCED
ON A YACHT‐‐
NOW THAT'S AN UNUSUAL BUSINESS
DEAL, AND WE'RE GONNA ENJOY
EVERY MINUTE OF IT.
(Tiffany) YES.
HELLO. NICE TO SEE YOU, TIFFANY.
HI. NICE TO SEE YOU, TOO.
WE'RE ON TRACK TO MAKE MILLIONS
WITH THIS PRODUCT,
AND IT JUST GOES TO SHOW YOU,
IF YOU HAVE THE RIGHT PRODUCT
WITH THE RIGHT PERSON,
ANYONE CAN SUCCEED.
♪♪
NEXT INTO THE TANK ARE
JIM DIMASCIO AND RAY LATYPOV,
WHO HOPE TO OPEN THE SHARKS'
EYES TO A WHOLE NEW WORLD.
♪♪
HELLO.
MY NAME IS RAY LATYPOV.
I AM CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF VIRTUSPHERE, INC.
HELLO. MY NAME IS
JIM DIMASCHIO,
AND I AM THE CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER OF VIRTUSPHERE, INC.
WE ARE SEEKING AN INVESTMENT
OF 1 AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS,
AND WE ARE WILLING TO OFFER
10% EQUITY IN OUR COMPANY.
WHOA.
YIKES.
WOW.
YOU ARE ONE CRAZY CHICKEN.
VIRTUSPHERE IS A VIRTUAL REALITY
LOCOMOTION SIMULATOR
THAT IS GOING TO DRAMATICALLY
CHANGE SIMULATION TRAINING.
VIRTUSPHERE IS ALSO
GOING TO REVOLUTIONIZE
VIRTUAL ENTERTAINMENT
BY ALLOWING PEOPLE
TO PLAY INSIDE
THEIR FAVORITE VIDEO GAMES.
WE'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU
A DEMONSTRATION,
WHICH RAY IS GONNA PERFORM
FOR YOU.
(O'Leary) WHOA.
OH! (laughs)
OUR HARDWARE SET CONSISTS
OF A 10‐FOOT SPHERE
WHICH IS PLACED ON A SPECIAL
PLATFORM THAT ALLOWS THE SPHERE
TO ROTATE, UH, FREELY,
IN ANY DIRECTION,
ACCORDING TO USER STEPS.
WHAT HE SEES
IN THE HEAD MOUNT DISPLAY,
YOU'RE WATCHING ON THE MONITOR.
WE TRANSMIT
A VIRTUAL ENVIRONMENT
TO OUR WIRELESS
HEAD MOUNT DISPLAY,
AND THE USER CAN MOVE FREELY
360 DEGREES,
GETTING THE MOST IMMERSIVE
VIRTUAL EXPERIENCE.
I GOTTA TRY THIS.
OKAY.
CAN I GO INSIDE?
SURE.
(O'Leary) YEAH? LET'S GO.
WHAT IS THE END PURPOSE,
THOUGH?
WHY DOES SOMEBODY NEED TO GET
INTO THERE TO DO THAT?
FOR COMBAT TRAINING.
WE CAN PUT A SOLDIER
IN THE MIDDLE OF BAGHDAD AND GO
THROUGH SIMULATION TRAINING,
BOTH AS A SINGLE
AND AS A MISSION REHEARSAL
AS A TEAM.
(O'Leary) SO, UH, ALL RIGHT.
YOUR‐‐YOUR HEAD INSIDE.
PLEASE BE CAREFUL.
YEAH. YEAH.
AND NOW YOU COULD
STEP INSIDE.
ONE MORE STEP, PLEASE.
SMALL STEPS. THANK YOU.
AND PLEASE WAIT.
WE WILL CLOSE THE HATCH.
SEAL ME
INTO THE PLEASURE DOME.
(Barbara and Daymond laugh)
(beep)
OKAY, SO I'M LOOKING
AT THE TELEVISION SCREEN,
AND I'M WALKING.
(Ray) BE CAREFUL.
BE CAREFUL.
WHOA.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE.
REALLY?
(O'Leary) YEAH.
NOW AND AGAIN,
AS YOU CAN WATCH,
HE'S PHYSICALLY MOVING
IN HIS VIRTUAL ENVIRONMENT,
SO NOW HE'S MOVING DOWN
THE FIXTURE OF THE WALL.
YEAH, BABY.
GERBIL IN THE RAT RACE.
(Jim) AND WHEN HE LOOKS DOWN,
HE'LL SEE THE SIDEWALK.
WHEN HE'LL LOOK UP,
HE'LL SEE THE BLUE SKY.
(O'Leary) OKAY,
I'VE GOT IT, GUYS.
DID YOU GET DIZZY AT ALL?
DID YOU GET DIZZY?
(Barbara) YEAH,
DID YOU GET DIZZY INSIDE?
IT'S PRETTY WILD.
REALLY? DID YOU FEEL DIZZY?
IT'S DISORIENTING. IT TAKES
SOME TIME TO GET USED TO.
(Daymond) FEEL A LITTLE
DISORIENTED THERE?
SO THE PURPOSE IS
TO TRAIN MARINES?
ABSOLUTELY. TRAIN ANY SOLDIERS
ON THE GROUND.
IMAGINE, WITH VIRTUSPHERE,
PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE
TO BE TRAINED
IN VIRTUAL DANGEROUS ENVIRONMENT
WITHOUT THE RISK
FOR HUMAN LIFE.
HOW MUCH WOULD IT BE
FOR PEOPLE'S HOMES?
DO YOU‐‐
IS THERE AN APPLICATION?
IN FUTURE, THE PRICE COULD DROP
MAYBE EVEN TO $10,000,
BUT RIGHT NOW, THE PRICE,
UH, IS $55,000.
AND GOING BACK
TO THE GAMING APPLICATION‐‐
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT I CAN ADD
TO AN EXISTING GAME?
YES, WE CAN. THE BIGGEST
ASSET ABOUT VIRTUSPHERE
IS OUR DIVERSITY IN MARKETS,
FROM MILITARY TO VIDEO GAMES
TO ENTERTAINMENT TO FITNESS.
BUT THIS IS CLEARLY
NOT GOING TO BE AN EASY SELL
TO THE CONSUMER IN THEIR HOME.
YOU'RE THINKING MORE OF
AN ARCADE ENVIRONMENT FOR THIS?
VIRTU‐VIR‐VIRTUAL
ARCADES.
SO AGAIN, BASED ON THE SAME,
UH, PRINCIPLE
AS A PAINTBALL OR LASER TAG,
WE WOULD ADD MULTIPLE SPHERES
IN A ROOM JUST LIKE THIS,
WHERE TEN SPHERES‐‐
PEOPLE WOULD COME IN TOGETHER,
PLAY AGAINST EACH OTHER,
INSIDE THE SAME
VIRTUAL ENVIRONMENT.
I‐I BUY IT. I SEE
THE APPLICATION. FANTASTIC.
BUT ALL THREE OF US KNOW
THAT YOU ARE LIGHT‐YEARS AWAY
FROM A CONSUMER APPLICATION.
WOULD YOU AGREE?
YES.
HAVE YOU SOLD ANY TO MILITARY?
YEAH.
FOR HOW MUCH?
E‐EACH OF THEM,
WE'VE SOLD FOR $50,000.
WHAT'S IT COST YOU
TO BUILD ONE OF THESE?
$14,000.
HOW MANY DO YOU HAVE TO SELL
IN A YEAR
FOR YOU TO BE PROFITABLE?
30.
30?
YES.
SO I CAN BUY 10% OF YOUR COMPANY
FOR 1 MILLION AND A HALF,
WHICH TELLS ME YOU THINK
IT'S WORTH $15 MILLION,
AND YOU HAVEN'T MADE ANY MONEY
YET. IT'S A HELL OF A BET.
WHAT MARKET WOULD YOU PICK
YOU THINK HAS
THE LEAST PATH OF RESISTANCE
TO SELLING 30 OF THESE SPHERES?
THE ARMY RECRUITING CENTERS.
THERE ARE 1,600 RECRUITMENT
CENTERS ACROSS AMERICA,
AND LAST YEAR THEY HAD
A $7.7 BILLION BUDGET.
THE U. S. ARMY ALONE
HAS 400,000 SOLDIERS.
SO AGAIN, WE CAN HELP THEM
RECRUIT NEW STAFF,
AND THEY HAVE AN EXISTING GAME
CALLED "AMERICA'S ARMY."
WE'VE OPENED UP A DISCUSSION
TO MAKE A COMPATIBLE VIRTUSPHERE
WITH THEM.
IMAGINE PUTTING A VIRTUSPHERE
IN AN ARMY RECRUITMENT CENTER.
PEOPLE WILL BE LINING UP
AT THE DOOR
TO AT LEAST TALK TO THEM,
GIVING THEM A HOOK
TO GET PEOPLE IN THE DOOR
TO HELP OUR COUNTRY FIGHT WARS
ACROSS THE NATION.
JIM, WHAT WOULD YOU DO
WITH THE MONEY?
THERE ARE 59 MILITARY BASES
THAT WE'VE TARGETED
THROUGHOUT AMERICA TO GO VISIT,
TO DEMONSTRATE,
TO PROVE A CONCEPT. WE CAN GO
TO THE THEME PARK INDUSTRY.
THE MORE I THINK ABOUT IT,
THE FARTHER AWAY
I THINK THIS IS
FROM A CONSUMER APPLICATION,
IF EVER.
WHAT‐‐WHAT DO YOU‐‐
WHAT DO YOU THINK, KEVIN?
I‐‐
DO YOU EVER SEE THIS
GOING TO A CONSUMER LEVEL?
I'M‐‐I'M REALLY TORN ON THIS.
I SEE IT
AS AN ARCADE OPPORTUNITY.
I MEAN, YOU THINK ABOUT‐‐
THE AVERAGE HOME IS NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO TAKE
THAT SPHERE IN.
"HONEY, THE DOME IS HERE."
(laughs)
(O'Leary) LIKE,
THINK ABOUT THAT. IT IS UNIQUE.
THERE'S NO QUESTION. I'VE NEVER
SEEN ANYTHING LIKE IT.
THANK YOU.
BUT I'M OUT.
OKAY. THANK YOU.
JIM, I‐I HAVE TWO PROBLEMS.
YEAH. YEAH.
IF THIS BECAME
A CONSUMER APPLICATION,
THERE'D BE, I THINK,
A LOT OF LIABILITY
FROM PEOPLE GETTING HURT
INSIDE THE BALL.
AND SECONDLY, IT'S‐‐
I THINK IT'S A LONG TIME
BEFORE I WOULD GET
MY MONEY BACK, SO I'M OUT.
OKAY, THANK YOU.
IT'S SUCH A BOY THING.
I CAN'T EVEN RELATE TO IT,
AND IT'S CERTAINLY TOO RICH
FOR ME, SO I'M OUT.
I THINK YOU NEED
A STRATEGIC PARTNER,
WHICH I WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO ASSIST YOU WITH THIS.
I THINK THERE'S
A LOT OF MAINTENANCE
AND‐‐AND A WORLD OF THINGS
I HAVE NO IDEA ABOUT. I'M OUT.
I'VE NEVER HAD AN IDEA
IN THE SHARK TANK
THAT I LOVED THIS MUCH.
IT JUST‐‐IT'S SO EARLY,
AND THERE'S NO DATA.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW
WHO'S GONNA BUY IT.
HAVING SOLD 10 OR 15 OF THEM,
IT'S‐‐IT'S SO FAR AWAY
FROM THE 1 AND A HALF MILLION
YOU'RE ASKING FOR.
IT'S A TOUGH ONE.
UM...
TOO MANY QUESTIONS. I'M OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
(Daymond) GOOD LUCK.
IT‐‐IT IS PRETTY AMAZING.
♪♪
DAYMOND, YOU GOTTA SEE
THIS THING INSIDE.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
THIS IS THE ULTIMATE BOY TOY.
IT'S LIKE A WHOLE NOTHER WORLD
IN THERE. LOOK AT THAT THING.
IT'S AMAZING
WHAT PEOPLE INVENT.
(Daymond) WOW!
(laughs)
(Daymond) THAT'S NICE.
♪♪
MY NAME IS GAYLA BENTLEY,
AND I'M A FASHION DESIGNER.
HOLD THAT RIGHT UP.
LET ME SEE
THESE DIFFERENT COLORS.
YEAH.
THERE IS A VOID
IN THE RETAIL WORLD
FOR HIGH‐END, BEAUTIFUL CLOTHES
FOR THE MODERN WOMAN,
SIZES 12 AND UP.
YES.
I LOVE THAT.
I CALL HER THE MODERN WOMAN
BECAUSE 60%
OF THE AMERICAN WOMEN
WEAR A SIZE 12 OR ABOVE.
IT'S AMAZING THAT NO ONE IS
REALLY CATERING TO THIS MARKET.
TWIRLY. (laughs)
(woman) TWIRL IT.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL WOMEN
HAVE A CHANCE TO BUY DESIRABLE,
BEAUTIFUL, HIGH‐END CLOTHES,
NOT JUST THE SKINNY MODELS
YOU SEE IN THE MAGAZINES.
I HOPE THE SHARKS
WILL HELP ME WITH MY MISSION
AND SEE THAT THIS IGNORED MARKET
IS A GOLD MINE.
♪♪
HELLO.
MY NAME IS GAYLA BENTLEY,
AND I AM THE DESIGNER
AND FOUNDER
OF THE GAYLA BENTLEY
FASHION DESIGN GROUP.
AND I AM HERE TONIGHT
TO ASK YOU
FOR YOUR WISDOM
AND YOUR EXPERIENCE...
WHAT ABOUT THE MONEY?
AND‐‐GOOD QUESTION‐‐
$250,000
FOR A 20% EQUITY STAKE
IN MY COMPANY.
I AM REPRESENTING 60%
OF THE AMERICAN WOMEN
THAT WEAR A SIZE 12 OR LARGER.
YOU KNOW US.
WE'RE YOUR NEIGHBOR,
YOUR SISTER, YOUR FRIEND.
AND WE ARE TIRED OF BEING
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST,
BEING FORCED TO SHOP
IN THE FAR CORNERS
OF THE DEPARTMENT STORES,
ONLY TO FIND CLOTHES THAT DON'T
FIT AND THAT WE DON'T EVEN LIKE.
I'VE SPENT THE LAST TEN YEARS
FOCUSING ON BUILDING
THE GAYLA BENTLEY BRAND‐‐
MODERN SIZES FOR MODERN WOMEN,
SIZES 12 TO 28.
WE WOULD LIKE TO OPEN OUR FIRST
GAYLA BENTLEY FLAGSHIP STORE
IN HOUSTON, TEXAS,
WHERE I'M VERY, VERY POPULAR.
LIKE, BARBARA,
IF YOU AND I WENT SHOPPING,
HOW COME WE HAVE TO SPLIT? "OH,
I'LL SEE YOU IN A LITTLE WHILE.
"I'LL GO UPSTAIRS
WITH MY FLASHLIGHT
"AND TRY TO FIND SOMETHING
TO WEAR. YOU JUST STAY DOWN HERE
ON THE FIRST FLOOR, WHERE
EVERYBODY WILL HELP YOU." OKAY?
THIS IS WHY I WANT TO PUT
THESE TYPE OF THINGS
ON THE FIRST FLOOR,
INTEGRATE THE SIZES.
I'VE DEDICATED MY LIFE TO THIS
FOR 30 YEARS NOW.
I'VE BEEN IN RETAIL MANAGEMENT
FOR SAKS FIFTH AVENUE.
BUT YOU'RE ONLY 25.
HOW CAN THAT BE?
OH, MY GOD. DARLING. ANYWAY,
LET ME CONCENTRATE FOR A MOMENT.
(Daymond) THAT'S RIGHT.
(laughs)
IS IT POSSIBLE
THAT LARGER‐SIZED WOMEN‐‐
AND DON'T BEAT ME WITH A STICK,
'CAUSE I'M JUST TRYING
TO FIND OUT...
OKAY, 'CAUSE THERE ARE
FOUR OF THEM HERE.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY, I'LL TRY NOT TO.
DON'T CARE ABOUT FASHION
AS MUCH?
THAT'S WHY THE MARKET
DOESN'T SERVICE THEM?
OH, MY. MY, MY, MY. OH.
GAYLA, BEAT HIM WITH A STICK.
BEAT HIM WITH A STICK.
OH, MY GOSH.
I‐‐NO, BUT, GAYLA, I BELIEVE
THE MARKET ALWAYS SERVES DEMAND.
YES.
THAT'S THE WAY THE WORLD WORKS.
BUT THERE ALWAYS HAS TO BE
ONE PIONEER.
IS THAT YOU?
IT'S GONNA BE ME,
WITH YOUR HELP AND WISDOM.
WHAT‐‐CAN YOU TELL US WHAT
THESE ITEMS SELL FOR RETAIL
AS YOU DEMONSTRATE THEM?
YES, THIS WOULD SELL
FOR $470.
$470?
YES. IT'S A LUXURY COAT.
WOW. PRETTY.
IT'S ITALIAN WOOL, VERY
LIGHTWEIGHT AND VERY TAILORED.
WHAT IS THAT COSTING YOU
TO MAKE,
THAT‐‐THE‐‐THE JACKET?
$125.
(Barbara) WOW.
NO.
OKAY. HEY.
(Robert) WOW.
(laughs)
YOU ARE GETTING THAT
AT $125? THAT'S ITALIAN WOOL?
YES.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL JACKET.
THANK YOU.
WHAT RETAIL STORES ARE YOU IN?
I AM ONLINE
WITH NEIMAN MARCUS.
SO, GAYLA, YOU DON'T HAVE
A STORE NOW?
YOU ONLY WHOLESALE‐‐YOU
WHOLESALE GOODS TOTALLY?
I'VE ONLY BEEN WORKING
IN WHOLESALE, YES.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES TODAY?
MY SALES
IN THE LAST SIX YEARS
ARE A LITTLE UNDER
A HALF A MILLION.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
$500,000 OVER 6 YEARS?
OH, NO, A YEAR.
OH, WELL, THAT...
OH, A YEAR.
OH, SORRY, DARLINGS.
WE THOUGHT YOU WERE DOING
UNDER $100,000 A YEAR.
OH, NO, NO, NO. WE COULDN'T
SURVIVE. LOOK AT US.
WE'RE VERY HIGH MAINTENANCE.
WELL, THAT'S‐‐THAT'S‐‐
MY NEXT QUESTION WAS...
YOU KNOW WE NEED MORE MONEY
THAN THAT.
MY NEXT QUESTION WAS GONNA BE
WHAT DO YOU EAT?
WHAT DO YOU SURVIVE ON?
WELL, YOU CAN SEE
WE'RE EATING CARBOHYDRATES.
THAT'S ALL WE CAN AFFORD,
YOU KNOW?
(sharks laugh)
SO‐‐
OKAY, GAYLA, SO I'M STUCK
ON ONE THING, AND IT‐‐
OKAY.
THE SKINNY BUYER
THAT BUYS FASHION‐‐
THEY WON'T PUT LARGER SIZES
INTO RETAIL.
I GOTTA KNOW WHY.
WHY, GAYLA?
YES, CAN I TELL YOU WHY?
(Daymond) YEAH.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY CLOTHES
IN THEIR LUXURY RETAIL SPACE
OVER A SIZE 12.
YES, I‐I UNDERSTAND THAT.
THAT'S WHY THIS IS
SUCH A GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
(Daymond) YEAH.
BUT WHY DON'T THEY HAVE THEM?
BECAUSE IT'S NOT THE "LUXURY"
LOOK. WHEN WE ARE‐‐
(Robert) IS THAT TRUE, DAYMOND?
(Gayla) THAT'S WHY WE'RE TIRED
OF BEING DISCRIMINATED AGAINST.
(Robert) I FIND THAT
HARD TO BELIEVE.
NO, IT'S TRUE.
TO THE WORLD,
LUXURY IS NOT PLUS SIZES.
THIS IS NOT LUXURIOUS?
NOT TO THEM,
NOT TO THE WORLD RIGHT NOW.
WE NEED SOMEONE TO BE A PIONEER,
TO BREAK THROUGH.
I JUST WANT TO ASK THE MOST
IMPORTANT QUESTION,
WHICH IS, BARBARA‐‐
YOU HAVE TO BE HONEST‐‐
IS THIS SOME GOOD STUFF?
I HAPPEN TO THINK THE CLOTHING'S
BEAUTIFUL, WITHOUT A DOUBT,
AND I THINK THE ATTENTION
TO DES‐‐DETAIL, UH,
IS USUALLY VERY EXPENSIVE
TO BE DONE.
(Daymond) RIGHT.
DAYMOND, IS HER IDEA
TO NOW EXPAND THE LINE
BY OPENING UP A FLAGSHIP STORE
THE RIGHT STRATEGY?
IT ALL DEPENDS.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DO BELIEVE THAT SHE CAN
MAKE A NEW SPACE.
I MEAN,
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I DID.
THERE WAS NOT
A YOUNG MEN'S MARKET IN 1990,
UNTIL WE MADE THAT SO‐CALLED
"URBAN SPACE." SO SHE‐‐
BUT, DAYMOND, HANG ON A SEC.
IF FASHION IS REALLY ABOUT
THE BRAND, THE DESIGNER,
WHY GO AFTER JUST LARGE?
WHY CAN'T SHE GO AFTER
THE ENTIRE MARKET?
SEE, AND‐‐AND THAT IS
A GOOD POINT, BECAUSE THAT‐‐
SOME OF THESE PIECES, I THINK,
WOULD BE ATTRACTIVE ON ANYBODY.
WELL, THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
I LOVE THIS STUFF.
(Gayla)
THANK YOU FOR SAYING THAT.
BUT IT'S A CROWDED FIELD
IF YOU GO OUT THERE
AND‐‐AND PUT THOSE DESIGNS TO‐‐
BUT THEY DON'T WANT TO BUY
THE LARGE STUFF.
EXCUSE ME. I WANT TO MENTION
THAT I DIDN'T MENTION
IT'S A $30‐BILLION‐A‐YEAR
INDUSTRY,
AND WOULDN'T YOU LIKE
A PIECE OF THAT PIE?
GAYLA, YOU'VE DONE A GOOD JOB
OF GETTING TO THIS POINT.
THANK YOU.
LET'S GO BACK TO THE $250,000
FOR A SECOND, FOR ME.
THANK YOU. OKAY.
WHY DO YOU NOW WANT
TO TAKE $250,000
AND OPEN A RETAIL STORE?
AND AS AN INVESTOR, HOW WOULD
I EVER GET MY MONEY
OUT OF SINKING IT
INTO ONE RETAIL LOCATION?
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA ROLL IT OUT
INTO OTHERS.
THIS WILL BE THE FIRST ONE,
IN THE SIMON MALLS.
TH‐THIS IS THE WORST TIME
IN THE HISTORY OF RETAIL‐‐
BUT LET ME TELL YOU,
SINCE THE FIRST QUARTER,
THE WHOLESALE WENT DOWN, SO I
HAD TO THINK QUICKLY ON MY FEET,
'CAUSE I DON'T WANT TO STOP
MY MOMENTUM.
I SAID, "WHY DON'T WE TAKE
THE FRONT PART
OF OUR WHOLESALE SHOWROOM
AND TURN IT INTO RETAIL?"
WE'RE UP 137%, WITH MY AVERAGE
SALE BEING $1,000.
GOOD FOR YOU.
WHY DO YOU NEED $250,000 FROM ME
TO OPEN UP A RETAIL STORE?
WHY NOT JUST DO IT
ON YOUR OWN?
I‐I'VE GONE TO THE BANKS,
AND THEY'RE NOT IN THE MOOD
TO LEND RIGHT NOW.
I'M SURE THAT'S THE CASE.
GAYLA, THERE'S SO MANY
DIFFERENT, UM, PRODUCTS HERE,
AND WHEN I DO AN INFOMERCIAL,
I HAVE ONE PRODUCT...
RIGHT.
IN 30 MINUTES.
WHEN I SEE ALL THE SIZES,
AND NOW TO COUPLE THAT
WITH RETAIL,
IT'S A VERY SCARY BUSINESS
FOR ME, SO I'M GONNA LEAVE THIS
TO THE EXPERTS HERE.
BEFORE YOU GO OUT‐‐
BEFORE YOU GO OUT...
YEAH.
WHICH IS‐‐IS THAT
WHERE YOU WERE GOING?
I'M GOING OUT, YEAH.
YOU'RE SURE?
I HAVE TO, YEAH,
BECAUSE IT‐‐IT‐‐
LET ME JUST STOP YOU
A MINUTE. OKAY?
I'VE BEEN WATCHING QVC.
THERE'S SOME ADORABLE LITTLE GUY
THAT DEMONSTRATED
HIS CLOTHING EXACTLY LIKE
SHE'S DEMONSTRATING, AND HE'S
SELLING OFF THE SHELVES.
I HAVE, RIGHT NOW, A HOME
SHOPPING NETWORK PURSUING ME.
I DID NOT WANT TO SIGN
ANY CONTRACTS...
(Barbara) MM‐HMM.
UNTIL I CAME TO SEE YOU ALL,
'CAUSE I NEED SOMEONE
WITH YOUR WISDOM AND EXPERIENCE
TO HELP MAKE SURE
I MAKE THE RIGHT DEAL.
AND SHE'S ADORABLE.
SHE'S GOT THAT INSTANT,
THINKING‐ON‐HER‐FEET CHARM.
SHE'S GONNA ROMANCE‐‐
I THINK I'D DO GREAT ON THAT.
WE WANT TO DO THE DEAL,
BUT I DON'T WANT TO DO IT‐‐
MAKE SURE I MAKE THE RIGHT DEAL.
GAYLA, I‐I LOVE THE STORY.
I‐I HAVE A HUGE AMOUNT
OF RESPECT
FOR THE SALES
YOU BUILT IN YOUR BUSINESS.
BUT BRICKS AND MORTAR
IS THE WRONG STRATEGY.
I KNOW ENOUGH TO KNOW
THAT'S WRONG.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT...
WITH A HEAVY HEART.
OKAY, BUT I AM FLEXIBLE,
AND I AM OPEN
TO WHAT WE THINK WOULD BE
THE BEST THING TO DO HERE.
I THINK THE HOME SHOPPING
IS A GOOD WAY TO GO,
BECAUSE I THINK IT BUILDS
MY GLOBAL BRAND,
WITH MORE PEOPLE LOOKING‐‐
I GOTTA GET MY NAME OUT THERE.
BUT ALL ROADS LEAD
TO THIS FACT‐‐
YES OR NO, TRUE OR FALSE‐‐
YOU ARE SHUT OUT OF RETAIL,
WHERE 90% OF CLOTHES ARE SOLD?
OH, MY GOD.
YOU ARE REALLY RUTHLESS.
NO. NO. I'M TELLING THE TRUTH.
YOU ARE REALLY RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
GAYLA, I CANNOT BE THE PIONEER
WITH THE ARROWS IN MY BACK,
ALL RIGHT?
DARLING, IT'S OKAY.
I AM OUT.
THAT'S QUITE ALL RIGHT.
GAYLA, I WAS GONNA SAY IT
BEFORE,
BUT I'M GONNA SAY IT NOW‐‐
THANK YOU SO MUCH, BUT I'M OUT.
YOU SURE YOU DON'T WANT TO
CONSIDER GOING IN HALF, KEVIN?
I CAN'T IMAGINE YOU CAN'T SELL
THIS STUFF ON THE AIR.
BARBARA, ARE YOU
ON COMMISSION WITH HER?
I MEAN, I'VE NEVER SEEN
A SHARK WORK SO HARD
TO BRING
SOMEBODY ELSE BACK IN.
I LOVE THIS LADY, AND YOU'RE NOT
GIVING HER THE CHANCE,
AND YOU GUYS AREN'T MARRIED
TO HEAVYSET LADIES. THE TRUTH‐‐
HE'S ON HIS THIRD, FOURTH,
FIFTH‐‐A TROPHY WIFE OR‐‐
WHAT DOES ANY OF THIS
HAVE TO DO WITH MAKING MONEY?
(Barbara) OKAY, ALL SKINNY.
ALL RIGHT?
SHE'S TALKING ABOUT ME?
(Robert) WHAT?
SHE TALKING ABOUT YOU?
WHAT IS SHE TALKING ABOUT?
YEAH. I'M TRYING
TO PROMPT HIM TO GET IN,
BECAUSE I THINK YOU SHOULD
JUMP IN ON THIS.
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
DAYMOND'S TROPHY WIFE
OR KEVIN'S TROPHY WIFE?
(Barbara) THEY ALL HAVE THEM.
(O'Leary) WHAT DOES THAT HAVE
TO DO WITH MAKING MONEY?
I GOT TWO PUPPIES.
I ONLY GOT TWO PUPPIES. I DON'T
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT LISTENING.
HERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY
IN AN AREA YOU CAN DO WELL WITH.
OPEN YOUR EARS.
I'LL PUT IN HALF THE MONEY
IF YOU CAN GET THIS
CLOTHING KING AND TELL THEM‐‐
GIVE THEM ONE MORE REASON
TO GO IN WITH YOU.
(sighs)
♪♪
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
BARBARA HAS OFFERED
TO GIVE GAYLA $125,000,
WHICH IS ONLY HALF THE MONEY
THAT SHE IS SEEKING.
GAYLA MUST CONVINCE DAYMOND
TO PUT UP ANOTHER $125,000
OR SHE'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
(sighs) DAYMOND,
MAY I ASK YOU A QUESTION?
YES.
WITH THE SUCCESS YOU'VE HAD
WITH YOUR CLOTHING LINE,
YOU HAVE A BUILT‐IN CLIENTELE
FOR THE WOMEN THAT WEAR MY SIZE.
IT'D BE SUCH A NATURAL FIT FOR
THE TWO OF US TO DO BUSINESS,
BECAUSE YOU ALREADY HAVE
THE DISTRIBUTION
AND THE POWER IN THE INDUSTRY.
AND COMING OUT OF THE GATE, THIS
IS NOT JUST A GREAT OPPORTUNITY,
IT'S AN EXTRAORDINARY
OPPORTUNITY
FOR HIT‐‐TO HIT THIS
OUT OF THE BALLPARK.
LET ME...
I JOTTED DOWN SOME NOTES.
YOU HAVE TO CONVINCE ME
TO FALL IN LOVE WITH YOU,
AND THEN AFTER THAT...
OH.
YOU HAVE TO CONVINCE AMERICA
TO FALL IN LOVE WITH YOU.
DON'T LOSE THIS OPPORTUNITY.
YOU PROMISE THAT
YOU WILL NOT BLOW THIS?
I PROMISE. I PROMISE YOU.
I PROMISE YOU THAT.
YOU COULDN'T GET A MORE LOYAL,
HARDWORKING GROUP OF PEOPLE
THAN WE ARE.
HERE IS‐‐
HERE IS MY PROPOSAL.
I WOULD... WANT TO GO PARTNERS
WITH YOU IN THE COMPANY,
SO IT WOULD BE 50%
FOR THE $250,000.
IT WOULD BE CONTINGENT ON US
GETTING A DEAL
WITH A WOMEN'S HOUSE,
WHICH ARE MANY OF MY FRIENDS.
I KNOW BARBARA WANTS TO BE IN.
I FIND THAT THERE IS NO NEED
FOR BARBARA IN THIS DEAL.
HOW NICE.
BUT I DO VALUE THE FACT
THAT I WOULD HAVE A PARTNER
WITH SKIN IN THE GAME
THAT DOES KNOW
WOMEN'S FASHIONS.
AN ELOQUENT FEMALE
LIKE BARBARA
CAN TELL ME IT'S CRAP
OR IT'S NOT.
YES.
BARBARA, ARE YOU IN ON THIS,
SO I KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON?
ABSOLUTELY.
OKAY, LET'S DISCUSS THIS.
I WANT TO REMAIN
IN CREATIVE CONTROL,
BECAUSE I KNOW AND BELIEVE
WHAT THE WOMEN WANT.
AND CAN WE LOOK AT 45%?
KEEP IN MIND
THAT NORMALLY I ASK FOR 51%,
SO THE REASON
WHY I'M ASKING FOR 50%
IS SO YOU HAVE
CREATIVE CONTROL,
WE MAKE THESE DECISIONS
TOGETHER.
THAT IS WHY
I DID NOT MAKE IT 51%.
WE HAVE A DEAL.
GOOD.
OH, MY GOD!
YOU'RE FANTASTIC!
MWAH. MWAH.
MWAH. MWAH. MWAH.
NOW YOU CAN DO AS MUCH TOUCHING
AS YOU WANT
'CAUSE WE'RE PARTNERS.
DARLING, MWAH! OH, BARBARA,
THIS IS SO EXCITING.
(Daymond) OH,
THEY'RE CRYING ABOUT‐‐
THEY'RE CRYING.
WHAT A NICE TEAM YOU HAVE.
(Daymond) YOU GUYS ARE THEIR
FAMILY. YOU GUYS ARE FAMILY.
(Gayla) OH, COME SAY HELLO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
(Robert) CONGRATULATIONS.
(Daymond) THANK YOU.
I GUESS WE CAN PICK UP OUR SIGNS
AND GO HOME NOW. LET'S GO EAT.
(sharks laughing)
(blows kisses)
(Gayla whispers) OH, MY GOD.
THIS IS NOT JUST A VICTORY
FOR GAYLA BENTLEY.
IT'S A VICTORY FOR MODERN WOMEN,
FOR ALL SIZES TO HAVE STYLE.
NEXT WEEK ON "SHARK TANK"...
(both) ♪ MR. PONCHO ♪
WE'RE GONNA OFFER YOU $400,000.
UNFORTUNATELY,
I WOULD HAVE TO DECLINE.
WOW.
I'M SPEECHLESS.
WHAT ARE YOU OFFERING ME?
WELL, LET'S PULL OUT
A CALCULATOR.
HE GOT A CALCULATOR ON HIM.
YOU'RE SITTING ON MY CARPET
ASKING FOR MONEY,
AND I'M TELLING YOU
HOW I'D GIVE IT TO YOU.
$600,000 FOR 50%.
THIS ISN'T MONOPOLY MONEY.
YOU REALIZE THAT, BRIAN?
IT'S A BIG MISTAKE TO (bleep)
WITH ME ON THIS ONE.
ARE YOU‐‐
ARE YOU THREATENING ME?